foreign
[Music]
if he starts getting too crazy
we're going to be going Southbound
flower
I'm gonna get three with the phone
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
perimeter or flower
fuck fuck the police stops
give me your hands
[Music]
I'm sorry don't be sorry just give us
your hand that's it relax
all right
all right one at a time
all right relax
oh my God oh my God oh my God don't run
next time
[Music]
through here
relax give me your hand give me your
hand give me your hands
I'm sorry don't be sorry just use your
hand that's it relax relax
relax relax all right who got cuss all
right relax
all right one at a time stop moving dude
stop moving all right relax
oh my God
oh my God oh my God don't run next time